bang-bang what's up everyone
lunch money time well while she's trying
to get rich the rest of us just trying
to get her lunch money right I'm here
with the beautiful and intelligent
I know there are nova she's got a cheese
shirt on today looks like he went
through a cheese grater with this sure
she's it springy or summary what it
looks pretty polka-dotty to me but uh
lunch money get money get paid now
sponsored by block five go check it out
go in the description click on the link
you can use their interest-bearing
product to earn up to eight point six
percent interest literally you go and
you put money in your regular bank
account they pay you next to nothing
like 0.05 percent if you're lucky and
they rehypothecation out and lend it and
they make all the money and you don't
the bank gets rich and you don't well
while she's trying to get rich through
so let's try to get lunch money right
black 5 does the exact opposite you can
deposit either crypto or digital dollars
they'll lend it out they'll earn
interest and they will pay you up to
eight point six percent for doing it
there's risk go to your research check
them out I'm a huge fan investor user
and I know this [ __ ] out of plane about
block five almost on a daily basis let's
get what there's risk in that too of
annoying you yeah I'm not scared of you
I got the people you won't assault me on
here what's going on safe space okay so
the Nasdaq somehow in the middle of
everything that's going on hit new
all-time highs and it's important to
know that the index is dominated by
Apple Microsoft Amazon alphabet and
Facebook which half surge or the indexes
search forty five percent since late
March but it follows those stocks twenty
twenty madness man we got a pandemic
economic shock we've got social unrest
in all 50 states and Nasdaq hit at
all-time high you know what I think
about this unpredictable baby what you
know how people are always like oh we're
living in a simulation and I was like
those people are psychos if there's one
thing that
may even allow me to consider it a
little bit it's 20/20 well I feel like
our overlords are like what else can we
put them through and confuse the hell
out of them with I think the 60s were
even crazier there was a bunch of stuff
that went on in the 60s maybe we'll
cover that in another episode but I
agree but if you think about 60s
it's been 80 years where's that fourth
tering every 20 years is one stage hey
I'm just saying you know what the
turnings are now so basically there's
this thought process that 80 year life
cycles right it's about the lifetime of
a person that's not generated but every
80 years we get a repeat of a bunch of
stuff and they go through phases so this
is the first 20 or second 20 years 30
and for 20 years since the 60s which had
a bunch of crazy stuff around health and
economic and space travel and all this
kind stuff and so eight years later here
we go like I don't know it's got some
credibility to it
speaking of well the Nasdaq is hitting
an all-time high
why is the word recession on here well
if you had done your homework
I read the internet already now okay so
the National Bureau of Economic Research
is which is called the fat lady of
economic opera get it cuz like it's not
so it's it's saying that the expansion
peaked in February after a record 128
months and we are officially in a
pandemic driven recession uh I'm very
confused why because technically you
have to have 2 quarters of GDP
contraction to have a recession and we
haven't had two quarters yet of data ok
but the standard definition of a
recession is a decline in economic
activity that lasts more than a few
months so they're saying it they're
saying this recession may be short-lived
anyone who's called the fat lady and is
talking about definitions that include
terminology like lasts more than a few
months
that doesn't seem
very measurable to me what's a few
months is it two months five well I
believe the fat lady singing so I think
that the actual reality from you know
somebody who didn't go work on Wall
Street is that you need to have a
decline in economic activity for two
straight quarters to have a recession
and so you can't get called a recession
until you grab you two economic it's
likely it is likely we had q1 four point
eight percent drop in GDP in the United
States so if in q2 there's a drop in GDP
then yes it would be considered a
recession by definition but it's very
specific it's very measurable two
straight quarters of economic decline
equals recession is not T about the
recession because it's just people are
they start doing weird things in times
of chaos like coming up with definitions
that include a few months and they use
it to fit their news it's not a standard
I understand that's what the article
says which are also reading in or org
which probably isn't the apps
salude say all be all when it comes to
financial news and information and if
this group is saying that then it
questions their legitimacy because
everyone knows that a recession of two
quarters in a row but that's fine it's
not like I actually care that much about
it
wait can you do the head again but
that's fine okay if I sub my long hair I
could flip my hair around you could not
flip any yeah I could blow some with
Macy's dollars Macy's has raised four
point five billion dollar and dollar
dollars in its saying that it has
sufficient liquidity to weather the
pandemic okay but like the pandemic it's
kind of like almost over
no but here great great example JCPenney
bankrupt hurts bankrupt bailouts for the
airlines all this though I don't think
Macy's got a bailout
I don't think Macy's got PPP money I may
be wrong on that but I do not believe
we're sitting inside I'm scared of
flying out it was it was like from the
dinosaur era I was like this mat this
big you can't see guys don't tell her it
was the shadow of a bird
it wasn't the actual bird yes bigger
bigger the shadow looks bigger than the
actual bird have you ever seen where
they put the light on the wall and they
go like this you know they're going like
this and then it looks like a huge
dinosaur on the wall that's basically
what I've never seen going back to
Macy's they didn't as far as I
understand they did not take any sort of
bailout when I didn't take any PPP money
what they did is they what's the debt
and equity markets they literally went
to investors and said hey we need to
shore up our balance sheet so that we
can weather all of this economic shock
and that's what they did great the
system worked they ended up raising 2.15
billion in assets credit and 1.3 billion
in bond offering is it bond offering or
bonds both okay so I don't understand
why everyone else could have gone and
done this why do they go and scream and
yell to the Federal Reserve and the
government to bail them out I don't know
what the free market run man were free
market societies supposedly all the
capital has turned into socialist let's
go back to capitalism capitalism wins
it's awesome I love it Macy's good for
you New Zealand what's up I bet there's
lots of birds and dinosaurs in New
Zealand yeah after this I really want to
discuss that bird I um okay I should be
actor
go ahead how many times you're gonna say
that if I say it enough maybe somebody
will draft me for a mom I select me I
can do comedy I could do action movies
whatever you need you could do action
movies I saw you struggle to get off the
couch yesterday yeah but they have their
CGI now I don't have to do anything I
just stand there and go like this and
they have sound effects that it makes me
look like a karate master okay so New
Zealand people want to know who I
thought could play me in a movie
that's lighting personally I would pick
Mark Wahlberg Jason Statham or Denzel
Washington what do you think you're as
athletic is one of those guys Mark
Wahlberg's very athletic Jason Statham
he's like on another
alien Denzel Washington I think is
probably ain't got as many moves as he
once had I think he's a little bit older
now you know get a lot of shape it's
alright I'm a fan but you struggle
getting off the couch yesterday well no
that's cuz I was just being careful with
the carpet I don't want to hurt the
carpet go ahead what's going on New
Zealand first of all New Zealand's Prime
Minister is one of the youngest Prime
Minister's she is 39 years old the
country I'm just telling you it's good
is pretty impressive
okay the country had no active
coronavirus cases and no new infections
so they have officially declared that
they have eradicated the virus although
I feel like that's kind of a bold
statement because what if people just go
there from a country that has a lot of
cases and or what if somebody has it and
they didn't go to the hospital or they
didn't get tested right so again look I
mean obviously cases are going down
around the world in most places some
places actually going up Florida but I
do think that yeah for to the last three
or four days has been the highest number
of cases that because they're testing my
guess is that it's testing some people
argue it's because they open up their
economy who knows we'll never know the
answer um but I mean look it's great
that cases are going down in general I
hope that they did eradicate it but I
think it's a pretty like you said bold
claim to just say that that oh we
eradicated it without being able to have
100% certainty by their opening the
restaurants they're allowing weddings no
social distancing hugs kisses everything
only 22 people died nationally it's
pretty small even though they well they
shut their economy down for it yeah but
they have five million people so in all
of New Zealand yeah that's less than in
Manhattan yeah Bern New York City I
guess all right what's going on with the
Bitcoin movie okay Cameron Tyler okay
let's go let me say my piece
okay piece like P i ec e or p AC AC what
do they call those types of words where
they comment not
ooh the reporter doesn't know that
English command of the language I don't
know let's go I think it sounds like
alligator okay we'll call an alligator
that's what's going on the Bitcoin
movies okay so so Cameron and Winkle
sorry Cameron and Tyler went ill their
leaders called him Cameron Cameron and
Tyler Winklevoss are having a movie the
book the Bitcoin billionaires is getting
turned into a movie what they're having
a movie would be the happy baby
wait don't make me laugh attack so so
they're getting so can I just say why
I'm excited for them okay you say what
happened oh yeah there's a book called
the Bitcoin billionaires and it's being
adapted into a film Ben Mezrich wrote
the book who also wrote accidental
billionaires which was the story that
eventually became the social network the
movie about Facebook he wrote a book
called Bitcoin billionaires like he's
the same guy who wrote the social
network
oh that's cool okay we Ben Mezrich is an
author who's written like 20 books he
wrote the accidental billionaires which
is a book that book was then turned into
a movie called the social network then
then said wait a minute
I got my portrayal of Cameron and Tyler
wrong he then came back and wrote
Bitcoin billionaires which is about
Cameron and Tyler's kind of post
Facebook run in life that is now going
to be turned into a movie as well I
don't think that they have a name for it
yet but my guess is that it will be
fantastic Cameron and Tyler are going to
I think either funded or co-directed
with a group which should be pretty cool
and shout-out to Ben I've had him on the
podcast he's fantastic not always a
great writer great human and the book is
fantastic the podcast
she just doesn't pay it's amazing I
don't listen to that episode but this is
what I want to say about the Bitcoin
movie I'm really excited about Cameron
and Tyler Winklevoss because I feel like
they were kind of portrayed not great
in the social network and also like kind
of what happened with Facebook and now
they get their time in the spotlight
Cameron and Tyler are going to at the
end of all of this go down as some of
the best investors in the world that's
my my prediction in 2012 I think it was
a thousand eleven they bought one
percent of the Bitcoin network at the
time two hundred two hundred ten
thousand Bitcoin so do the math they got
bought of Bitcoin they also have a very
substantial and material holding of
ether the token for aetherium they
recently kind of came out and said that
Micah and then they also have the Gemini
exchange which is incredibly valuable as
well and so I think that when this is
all said and done if bitcoin ends up
doing what we think it will do those two
guys in particular will history will be
very very common do you think that what
happened with Facebook and Zuckerberg
fueled all of this for them you can get
motivated them all I will say is you can
get lucky once you don't get lucky twice
you don't there's your yeah there oh
they're incredibly intelligent you just
aren't around multiple inflection points
in technology business human history by
accident like they get it they every
time I've talked to them incredibly
impressive and I feel like they have a
very very long term view they have a
very deep conviction and good for them
like I can't wait for the movie to come
out yeah guys if you need somebody to
play a troll on Twitter just call me the
problem it's fine all even the you know
why is lighting a face for free go ahead
influencers what's up okay ready
so this is a cool move your student
athletes will soon be social media
influencers and one college program is
helping them direct so get this so 600
university of nebraska student athletes
yes they okay
unlike other student athletes in the
country from the senior starting point
guard to the redshirt javelin thrower
they each will have an entire team
dedicated to helping them build and
maximize their personal brands to the
University of Nebraska so basically this
is all because the n-c-double-a does not
pay them yeah they're complete cowards
the NCAA refuses to pay the athletes so
instead they've now kind of compromised
and said hey we won't pay you but you
can go and monetize your likeness and
your image so you can use your name to
sell things build social-media
followings do advertising all of that
kind of stuff
my god what are we CG eyes okay and then
I think that what universities are gonna
do is they cool if you're gonna going to
allow our athletes to monetize that way
one of the ways that we can help recruit
them here is say hey we have all this
infrastructure to help you become famous
and monetize your likeness and image
it's basically a way of telling them
like we'll pay you more money we're not
gonna pay the money we're gonna help you
get paid get money get paid
alternatively they could just pay them
yeah of course the n-c-double-a should
just be paying them right the idea that
there is a business in 2020 that
literally says you come work for me for
free I'm gonna make hundreds of millions
of dollars if not billions of dollars
off of you and you're gonna get paid
zero absurd and I get it people say oh
they get a scholarship they get whatever
right like look at the end of the day
they're creating way more economic value
than the education and to is imagine a
world that there was a Arian Foster who
was a college running back years ago
came out and he said that I think he was
at the University of Tennessee there was
a game where he went to the stadium
there was like 60,000 people there
chanting his name he had a monster game
they won the game University made
millions of dollars that day and he went
home and he looked in his refrigerator
and he had no food right and so he
called the coach he said yo coach man
you had to bring me some tacos cuz if
you don't I'm gonna do some crazy [ __ ]
I'm hungry
right and now that's an exaggerated like
very extreme case but basically it was
the idea of like look I just cradle all
this economic value for the University
for the team right around your brand all
this kind of stuff and I go home I only
have food in my refrigerator what's up
with that he just started a newsletter
I'm all about if you have value you
gotta get paid get money get paid
athletes are gonna get paid wait let me
tell you there's a chart of estimated
potential annual earnings through social
media
branding and adrian martinez who is a
football player and he has all these
followers he could make one hundred and
fifty three thousand dollars a year but
then there's Trinity gomez who's on the
rifle team and they'd be making one
hundred and sixty eight dollars see this
is a wild idea but I actually think
monetizing their social media is the
worst way for them to do this it's gonna
be the easiest for them to do because
it's so hey just create a following
online and then we can help you like
sell ads but I actually think what they
should do is the really really big star
should actually build companies or build
products same thing like people outside
those sports should be doing and so if
you're you know take a player so if
you're I don't know a basketball player
at Duke right you're the best player in
the country
you should literally go to Nike and say
hey why don't I license you my name
let's put it on a shoe and then we'll
sell it if you're the top top you know
1% of the 1%
yes but the universities are gonna want
to cut no that's that's the whole
thing's NC double-a is said that the
player gets the money oh right so now
all of a sudden you're gonna start
getting in this game of like it's kind
of like professional sports a lot of
professional athletes actually make more
money from sponsorships than they do
from their actual contracts and if
people get super sophisticated about
this like this could be a massive
industry maybe I should put my name on a
shoe first you should become athletic
and then you can do that alright guys
that's it today for less money
well while she's trying to get rich the
rest of us just trying to get a lunch
money right I could be an action hero
we'll talk to you guys tomorrow
bang bang hope you guys enjoyed this
episode of lunch money as much as we did
don't forget lunch monies now sponsored
by block five so go check them out
there's a link in the description that
you can click on I'm an investor a user
and a huge fan what you're a bigger fan
of block fire than you are of me block
wise my second favorite thing in the
world behind polina
they've got three products they can give
you a US dollar loan you can earn up to
eight point six percent interest on an
interest-bearing account or you can buy
and sell crypto currencies on their
crypto exchange I personally use the
interest-bearing account there's not
very many places where you'll find up to
eight point six percent interest on a
deposit
barring account go do your own research
there's risk associated but 8.6% it's
pretty compelling so click on the link
in the description say thanks to the
folks that block by subscribe to our
channel like the video annoy plan in the
comment and we'll see you guys tomorrow
and be kind to your friends